à partir de jeudi prochain tous les
élèves du secondaire devront porter le
couvre visage partout sur le terrain
autour des écoles on le porte évidemment
dans les aires communes comme c'est le
cas depuis le début on va devoir aussi
le porter en classe on aura une nouvelle
application cette application au niveau
de la sécurité elle a été testée par le
centre gouvernemental de cyber défense
du québec
c'est complètement anonyme c'est un
mécanisme facile automatique
les chiffres démontrent que si tu
utilises nombreux ratés la situation est
toujours très critique oui on y dort
cabinet piper secours aux riffs plus de
trente hospitalisation aujourd'hui à une
journée plus de 15 décès comment on est
arrivé à être c'est avec cette courbe là
c'est ça qui se pose comme question
aujourd'hui si on veut rester encore
drôle
il va y avoir des opérations de
délestage aujourd'hui je veux au nom de
l'état québécois au frais mes excuses à
la famille de joyce et chacun je
souhaite profondément qu'on reconnaisse
qu'ils ont des droits
probablement qu'on n'aurait dû jamais
parlé de déconfinement le gouvernement a
fini par marquer des scuds j'ai pas
trouvé jusqu'à présent un expert qui est
capable de me donner la recette mais on
la cherche
je trouve ça avance pas assez vite les
suite aux recommandations du rapport
vient je vais m'impliquer
personnellement une autre grande
priorité c'est d'augmenter le traçage
s'il veut freiner la propagation
s'il veut casser la deuxième vague le
retraçage c'est un des éléments clé
pourquoi il n'a pas demandé au
gouvernement fédéral un coup de main moi
je travaille avec les gens l'ontario je
travaille avec le fédéral nous allons
prendre comme nous l'avons fait la
preuve
à bâle toute l'aide qui est disponible
monsieur le président alors un reflet de
la semaine sur la coved et aussi sera
question du racisme systémique au carnet
politique avec françois cardinal
éditorialiste en chef au quotidien la
presse et ben non au corps de lee
chroniqueur politique aux devoirs
bonsoir à tous les deux pour cent soir
alors toute une semaine vous allez me
dire on a déjà répondu à toutes ces
questions là depuis le début depuis des
mois reste que du côté de la coved on a
pris peut-être un petit tournant
françois ou encore le ministre baird
donc annonce évidemment le port du
masque
vous avez des chroniqueurs chez vous qui
en demandait plus pure de sentir une
certaine mesure un agacement ou fatigue
du côté du gouvernement
même aujourd'hui le du côté le dr arruda
regard sur cette juste en crise cette
semaine de votre part oui même monsieur
legault aujourd'hui ont montré plusieurs
signes d'impatience c'est beaucoup plus
que dans les derniers jours dernières
semaines je pense que c'était l'image de
la semaine des dernières semaines le
bilan est assez difficile au québec sans
qu'on puisse toujours mettre le doigt
sur le bobo je pense qu'une partie de 2
du prix à payer pour notre relâchement
individuels et collectifs des dernières
semaines derniers mois
vous parliez des écoles je pense que
monsieur roberge agit dans conséquente
c'est à dire que vous avez des écoles
qui sont dans leurs communautés dans un
contexte où la transmission et
communautaire c'était normal qu'on serre
la vis dans les écoles même s'il n'y a
pas d'explosion des cas il ya une
augmentation des éclosions
je pense que c'est une bonne chose les
masques par exemple partout dans l'école
et c'est le seul bémol je dirais pour
les écoles mairie puis peut-être parce
que j'ai moi même un enfant de 17 ans on
avait promis de ne pas fermer les écoles
or en envoyant les jeunes de secondaire
4 et 5 une journée sur deux à l'école et
on ferme les écoles d'une journée sur
deux
de facto donc ça c'est me juge pas
certain que ce soit la mère de
l'enseignement ligne ça suffit pas à
remplace pas non et c'est surtout la
motivation qui suit pas on ne sait rien
alors pour vous maintenant parce que la
question que tout le monde se pose au
fond est ce qu'on peut faire mieux ce
qu'on peut faire plus parce que le
gouvernement est peut-être un peu sur la
défensive tout en rappelant qu'il ne
veut pas confiné je pense que le
gouvernement si je pense qu'il fait à
peu près tout ce qu'il peut la deuxième
vague pour se nourrir c'est puis sur les
restants de la première et on a eu la
plus grosse première vague de tout le
canada
alors inévitablement la deuxième à moins
que l'on comprenne des mesures encore
plus drastiques vont inévitablement plus
sévère qu'elle l'est dans les autres
provinces ou d'ailleurs on prend des
mesures un peu moins drastiques et
certains égards et la chose peut-être
des conseillers ont été confinés trouvé
en terme de ce qu'est prêt au
rassemblement par exemple parce qu'il
semble que ça a été la source de bien
des maux mais je ne voudrais pas d'avoir
souillé
si c'est du jamais vu tout ça et des
gens essaient autant qu'ils le peuvent
de s'appuyer sur les données
scientifiques mots il ya beaucoup
d'éléments qui nous manque pour ne
jamais rien géré de tel donc
inévitablement il ya deux laissés erreur
et on essaie de faire le moins d'erreurs
possible je pense qu'effectivement là
c'est une faiblesse qui a été dit noter
cette semaine c'est la question du
traçage on voit qu'ils manquent de
personnel ont fait appel aux gens sur je
contribue mais on apprend que c'est un
de fer par le fédéral a tardé à être
acceptés ou à être conclue finalement et
donc le monsieur le ministre dubé dit
d'ailleurs qui veut essayer d'éclaircir
pourquoi qu'il se retire parce que le
québec en a absolument besoin
c'est un maillon essentiel de cette
chaîne de contrôle de la transition mais
je pense que les messages sont beaucoup
plus claires comme cette semaine que les
semis un message plus clair françois mas
que le gouvernement malgré son optimisme
peut paraître départ dépassé par les
événements la complexité producteurs à
vous donnerai et on sait pas on peut pas
faire des recommandations sans tenir
compte de certaines expertises mais ça
va dans tous les sens aussi les
expertises
oui puis je les sentais quand même d
entrer aujourd'hui plus que les autres
jours dr arruda par exemple aujourd'hui
abandonné partie sur un long monologue
j'aime bien ce caractère authentique
tant mieux si on peut sortir des lignes
mais le dr arruda a alors dit qu'il ne
savait pas trop pourquoi le québec
on était dans une posture aussi
difficile par rapport à d'autres
juridictions similaires
rappelez vous il ya quelques jours il
avait parlé d'une souche de virus
différentes ça tient pas la route quand
on vérifie c'est le même virus pour la
deuxième vague qu'ailleurs au pays
et donc on sent quand même qu'à québec
sont désemparés il ya plusieurs facteurs
je vous parlais du relâchement des
québécois il ya aussi la machine qui
suit pas toujours maintenant on vient de
donner l'exemple mais des téléphonistes
de statistique canada qu'on n'a pas été
cherché mais il ya aussi le jeu
politique
on peut en parler mais l'application de
traçage coved alerte
je comprends mal le jeu des partis
d'opposition à québec qui ne sont pas
derrière le gouvernement pour faire
appel aux québécois pour que tout le
monde ou en tout cas le plus grand
nombre le thé les changes est pour vous
la question du traçage l'avait vaincu
aussi maintenant le gouvernement voulait
abandonner avoir sa propre application
mais là il doit bien se ranger avec les
autres provinces
mais c'est parce que si on veut que ce
soit efficace son temps entre honte à
tout lire tous les gens qui vivent dans
l'outaouais
la majorité des gens qui sont tous les
trois et a côtoyé fall le pont entre les
deux provinces l'ontario et le québec
c'est quand même un des grands ensembles
urbains du québec mais aussi bon pour
les gens qui voyagent ou qui ont pas le
travail
je ne sais que trop mais puis il ya des
gens qui ont exactement la même
application que cet appareil se mécanise
devient efficace je reviendrai sur la
question dont on sait pas trop pourquoi
ou des jeux par les scientifiques sur la
question qui suis qui suit ces
changements et qui dit vous savez en
sciences pour voir une vraie réponse
scientifique
on aura besoin de recul là on est encore
dans le feu de l'action où on essaie de
faire de notre mieux mais face à une
ennemie nouveau très connue avant d'une
ampleur mais de la région un peu dit
aujourd'hui aux adhérents rapidement
pour dire que le taraudait laisse
entendre un jour on aura des doctorats %
pensent n'a plus que dix jours étaient
des scientifiques mais ça reste ce que
c'est le mystère québec plus de l'accord
mais parce qu'on a vu la liste des corps
dans les données ces jours là on est
juste après les noix si je peux me
permettre
j'ai conçu monsieur dubé laissé entendre
pendant la semaine que le comportement
des québécois était petit oui
était peut-être des problèmes je pense
qu'il a raison on n'ose pas trop le dire
à québec pour ne pas montrer monsieur
leroux je passe le contredit les
citoyens mais exactement on veut pas
façon je veux pas mettre la faute sur
les citoyens mais en même temps les
courbes reflète le comportement de ces
mêmes citoyens là et je me souviens d'un
sondage léger à la rentrée qui montré
que 67 % des canadiens anglophones
craignait une deuxième vague craignent
d'attraper le virus alors qu'au québec
on était 40 3% à peine à voir cette même
inquiétude
donc on peut présumer derrière qu'un
relâchement idoine
je voulais vous avaient été rompues
l'être humain non pas que je vous
redonne la parole sur le même point
cette comparaison je prends oui ça mais
cette comparaison n'est est pas mauvaise
parce qu'on n'a pas la même culture au
niveau du rapport social niveau du
contact physique
d'ailleurs on le voit dans les sociétés
la team la propagation du virus souvent
se révèle très vigoureuse on se fait la
bise etc
mais oui une différence de culture de
comportement de négocier rapports
sociaux c'est évident oui mais il ya
d'autres raisons aussi qu'il faudra
étudier justement que vous analysez et
on espère ne jamais avoir à se servir
des leçons c'est troublant quand même
mot quand même sur la question de
monsieur legault le débat sur la notion
de racisme systémique et ses propos
aujourd'hui à l'égard de la ministre
maintenant je commence avec vous là
dessus il regarde je pense que on sait
la perte de confiance envers le ministre
qui le jour de 1er anniversaire du
rapport aux vielles un fêtard mais ne
mentionne nullement là
le drame de joyce et chaque fois alors
que c'est justement le manque de mise en
oeuvre d'accords du rap hardier et une
explique un peu aussi la situation qui
perdure dans des hôpitaux comme on
l'exigé
puis elle même et sur le dos de ghislain
picard interviewera près de la tuque
pour passer à vos indications pour soi
mais en juin dernier françois legault
voulait pas reconnaître l'existence d'un
racisme systémique en disant on va agir
en ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
n'a pas agi et on reconnaît toujours pas
le ressuscité mitoyen c'est un problème
et je pense que ça va être devenir un
boulet pour ce gouvernement alors s'il
n'agit pas s'il ne met pas des mots sur
les problèmes peut-être en nommant ne
serait-ce qu'en disant qu'il ya une
discrimination systémique pour moins
quand on nomme mais on peut être plus à
même de poirée 35 ans chacun indignation
françois le npd le npd en fait le npd
qui ne laisse pas la place à la chef des
verts qui se présentent en ontario dans
une élection partielle en 2019 on se
rappellera que jack médecins y avait eu
cette civilité là de la part des verts
qui lui avait laissé toute la place
je pense qu'il aurait pu lui leur
rendent la même là même le même
comportement aujourd'hui et pour vous
maintenant votre impression
mon indignation que monsieur je sais a
invoqué ce scénario complètement fictif
de danger de coûts d'un complot pour
renverser gouvernement bourassa lors de
la crise d'octobre de 70 alors qu'on
sait très bien que il se contrôle n'a
jamais existé que c'est une histoire en
musique
le père de monsieur trudeau et marc
lalonde ont soufflé dans l'oreille de
journalistes auront toi qui te dit oui
et tout ça parce que monsieur trudeau
cherche des raisons pour justifier de ne
pas s'excuser pour les atteintes aux
droits civils
fondamentaux de certains québécois qui
veut rien à voir avec toute cette crise
parce que même monsieur lalonde déjà
déclarée sûre nous osons dans le passé
que cette histoire de gouvernement
provisoire a fait complètement farfelu
non non voire 80 p départs contre
demandent aussi des excuses à monsieur
signe il ya eu monsieur marqueur la
gazette
eh bien merci françois merci maintenant
belle semaine françois je pense qu'on
retrouve chez avec céline plus tard oui
je veux pas m'asseoir et semaine
prochaine tous les deux